hopefully everyone is in full holiday
mode and getting ready to do all of that
holiday shopping but if you need a
little inspiration we have lifestyle
experts Samantha Vickers here with a lot
of fun things in front of us it's always
so great to see you so good to see you
and yes I smell that there's fragrances
vanilla in there I know yeah you can
spread this go ahead that's amazing and
this you can pick up at Macy's
um in store or you can go to macy's.com
so you can get it locally and have
something just unique and something
they're going to think of you every time
that they put it on that's great it
smells amazing it does and speaking of
smelling amazing we were talking earlier
I love anything miniature that you can
kind of put in your purse or take with
you tell us about that oh yes okay so
this is a little bit further away than
Macy's this is from across the pond and
it is penhaligan's world-renowned
fragrances and so we've got our leading
ladies here in the front and our showmen
I know aren't they adorable this set I
love it
um and really it's a great gift because
you can either keep it all together as
all five or individually gift them to
people and sometimes you don't know what
sense people like so it's fun that you
can try out a few different ones there's
got to be one in there that they'll love
about all of them absolutely and this
one you can get at penhaligans.com okay
I have to remember that one all right
moving on to this over here okay so this
is for that person in your life that is
maybe living a healthy lifestyle or they
want to so um tribest offers a whole lot
of products and I brought two of them
today and this one I know everybody's
like what is that trying to figure it
out before we started so this is
actually called a fresh life automatic
seed sprouter okay so this little guy
right here is what Waters all of your
Sprouts so all you have to do is put
water in the bottom you don't have to
mess with soil put this on top and sit
your seeds in there and then you're
going to put this on on the top here
plug it in it's amazing I know and in
five day days you're gonna have
beautiful lovely organic Sprouts that
you can either eat fresh or yep right
here dump it into your Dynapro high
speed vacuum blender this
what does that mean okay so a vacuum
blender it has all of the you know
goodies of a high speed blender yeah 2.5
horsepower it's going to really get
everything really really small and get
that nutrition out of there but it
oxidizes some of the nutrients and it
breaks it down when you do high speed
blending wow not with this so if you
push that button yes it'll make a little
noise okay all right you're going to
push it okay you can turn it off but
what that would do if you had something
in there is take all the oxygen out it's
going to give you a better blend a more
smooth texture and you're going to
retain that nutrition wow that is
amazing and we have to wrap up here
really quickly I just want to give us
the name of this really quick absolutely
this is at trybest.com okay this is La
laser hair removal they're here in town
they're local amazing permanent hair
removal go to La laserhairremoval.com
you always have the best out Samantha so
great to see you thank you so much for
being here something for everyone on
your list